so how do you identify competitors well
you could always just ask ask potential
customers how they solve the same need
you solve
so with abarkment we can go to a dog
park and talk to different dog owners
and ask them how they solve the problem
of having someone watch their dog while
they're on vacation we can ask them do
you take your dog to a kennel do you get
your dog walker to come a few times a
day when you're out do you ask your
friends to watch your dog when you're
gone we can try to find out how they do
research to figure out where to put
their dog maybe it's just word of mouth
between people maybe they go online
maybe they ask each other at the dog
park another way to identify your
competitors is to just search for them
yourself here let's try it with
abarkment
if I search dog sitting online I can see
who my biggest competitors are look the
first people who come up are Rover and
doggie vacay they're well-known names in
the industry and I can see who's buying
ads for this same keyword search I want
you to take a moment to think about your
own app idea or business idea who are
your competitors I want you to think
about some keywords you would use to
search for your potential business and
do some search queries to see who's at
the top of the list you can check out
the play store or any App Store to do
the same thing now if you don't have an
app idea feel free to use a barque mitt
but don't use the competitor examples we
already talked about insert the
competitors names in these three boxes